so let's continue our discussion we've
got the NRA we've got this 29 year old
Russian agent named Maria boo Tina who's
now been indicted for working on behalf
of Russia in the United States without
being a registered foreign agent we have
a viewer of the David Pakman show who
actually was at a class with Maria boo
Tina and exchanged emails with her and
he sent them to me and I've been
reviewing them and I don't know whether
they they're really relevant for the
show I don't know if he's okay with me
showing them to you but I've been
reviewing a lot of the activity that
Maria boo Tina has been involved in and
she appears to be at least one of the
conduits between the Russians and the
Trump campaign via the NRA and that's a
connection that we've been following for
months so I already told you in the last
story that the same day of Maria boo
Tina's indictment the Trump Treasury
headed by Steven minuchin decided to
change a rule to make it easier to hide
the donors of dark money to
organizations just like the NRA
convenient coincidence okay well
yesterday we learned that it wasn't just
the NRA that Maria boo Tina was meeting
meeting with it wasn't just showing up
at a trump event and asking Trump a
question about easing Russian sanctions
but Reuters is now reporting that Maria
boo Tina also met with two senior
officials at the United States Federal
Reserve and the Treasury Department
along with other visiting Russian
officials I'm not saying these things
are related but this stinks really
really badly and it now also pulls in
specifically Alexander tortion who
happens to be the exact Russian rich
dude who's already suspected of being a
funder of trumps campaign via the NRA
multiple people familiar with the
meetings involving boo Tina and the
Treasury and the Fed have confirmed that
including Americans who are connected to
those meetings so there is nothing being
questioned about whether these meetings
took place so consider what we now know
with regard to Maria boo Tina number one
Maria boo Tina met with high-ranking NRA
officials and of course we know that the
NRA was funneling money to the Trump
campaign number
- Maria boo Tina met with US Treasury
and Federal Reserve officials number
three the Treasury relaxed reporting
requirements of NRA donor information
within 48 hours of Maria boo Tina's
arrest and number four boo Tina worked
for NRA tied pootin connected Russian
Alexander torsion I also increasingly
don't understand how a twenty-something
year old Russian gets meeting after
meeting with NRA higher up Treasury
higher up Federal Reserve higher up and
nobody seems to raise an eyebrow and the
broader picture here is twofold number
one we now realize that Russia deployed
the full spectrum of infiltration
techniques you have Russians teasing
Trump campaign officials and Trump's own
family including Donald Trump jr. and
Kushner with dirt on Hillary and it got
them meetings at Trump Tower
you have the messing with the voting
systems by Russia in something like
twenty or more states and actually
accessing the voting systems in at least
one state as far as the latest reports
indicate you have infiltration of
traditionally right-wing organizations
like the NRA and the use of those
organizations as conduits to both the
Republican Party's easing of their
position on Russia and to the Trump
campaign itself and then lastly and some
people don't like this we don't know to
what extent Maria boo Tina may have used
sex to obtain even more than we know
about right so like it's not it's not
sexist to say that Maria boo Tina may
have used sex in order to develop some
of the connections that she did it's
just a widely used tactic by Russia and
other intelligence services and it's one
of the reasons why a woman operating in
a world that is disproportionately men
granting access it wouldn't be shocking
to think that that may be why this
twenty-something woman
with no real credentials to speak of was
able to get this level of access and
it's it's not sexist and in fact I don't
even know if we need to call it
infiltration what it seems like many of
these parties the Trump campaign the
Republican Party the NRA among others
willingly welcomed Maria boo Tina so
we're going to learn some incredible
things in the next few months this is
only the start and I really do want to
hear from our from the audience
particularly from the Russia skeptics on
this when you see the various modes of
infiltration that took place working
directly with the Trump campaign working
through conduits like the NRA and others
using individuals like Maria boo Tina to
meet with folks at everywhere from the
Federal Reserve and the Treasury to the
NRA how at this point can anybody still
be a so-called Russia skeptic let me
know this is a topic of discussion on
the David Pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our IDI di t and we've
got a fantastic program for you today I
am thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman blinka is a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka stakes the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about five bucks a month go to blink
accom slash Pakman that's bli nki st.com
/pa que ma n